Okay, so
how often can we expect to guess
correctly in a way prediction cache?
We can get an idea for this by looking
at the smaller direct mapped cache.
Basically, let's say we have
a two way set associative cache.
Each set of this cache has two ways,
two lines in it.
And by doing way prediction, we are
effectively using one of these at first.
And only if we don't find it there,
we look at the other one.
So effectively, a way prediction cache
first tries to access what looks
like a smaller direct mapped cache.
Then it will try the entire
set associative cache.
So we can get a pretty good estimate for
the hit rate and hit latency and so
on of a way prediction cache, if we
look at the direct mapped cache and
the set associative cache.
So let's look at the basic 32 kilobyte,
8-way set associative cache.
Let's look at its hit rate, hit latency,
miss penalty, and the over AMAT.
And we will also look at a 32 kilobyte,
8-way set-associative
cache with way prediction.
The hit rate of this cache,
let's say its around 90%.
The hit latency might be 2 cycle
because it's highly associative.
The miss penalty will be 20 cycles,
for example.
And the overall AMAT would then be 2 for
the hit latency,
plus 10% of the time we
have the miss penalty.
And we get 4 here.
Now we already said that way prediction
behaves like accessing only
one of the ways in the cache.
With way prediction in
a 8-way associative cache,
we are really guessing which of the 8
places is going to have the block.
So you effectively, with way prediction,
our first attempt will
be to a 4 kilobyte direct
mapped subset of this cache.
If we look at the normal 4
kilobyte direct mapped cache,
that's going to have, for
example, a 70% hit rate,
but the 1 cycle hit latency,
because it's faster.
And the miss penalty will be the same.
If we now try to get the AMAT for
this basic direct mapped cache,
we will have 1 + 0.3, the miss rate,
times 20, and this is going to
be 1 plus 6 so it gives us 7.
So obviously we are better off with
a 8 way set associative cache.
However, we are paying an extra
cycle each time we access it for
the hit latency in order to get
the low missed penalties here.
With the way prediction cache,
what we're getting is 70% of the time
we're going to find what we're looking
for in the 4 kilobyte subset that we
are checking first and
we will have a 1 cycle latency for that.
In the remaining 20%, we're going to
check the rest of the cache so
our overall hit rate will be 90%.
What we don't find here,
we will still find here if
it's in the 32 kilobyte cache.
So we get a 90% hit rate overall.
Our hit latency is now 1 or 2.
And our miss penalty is 20, so
how do we compute the AMAT?
Well, what we now have
is that 70% of the time,
we find what we are looking for
in one cycle.
The other 30% of the time,
whether we have a hit or
a miss in the 8-way cache,
we have to check it.
So the other 30% of the time we're
checking all of the ways for
which we pay a 2 cycle latency, and
then 10% of the time we don't find what
we are looking for in all of the ways,
so we have to pay the miss penalty.
So now we have what
looks like our hit time.
70% of the time, it's 1.
30% of the time, we have to use a 2, so
we end up having a 1.3
cycle on average hit time.
And a miss penalty of the 8-way
set associative cache
which is still going to be 2.
And this is how we improve things,
we now get an AMAT of 3.3.
Because what we effectively
got was the misses of an 8-way
set associative cache, but
the hit time that is much closer to
a direct mapped cache then it is
to an 8-way set associative cache.